these are the top three funniest moments
between Shane Gillis and Theo Von
starting off with Theo's first time on
Matt and Shane secret podcast can you
look that up you guys don't have anybody
that works here huh gay he no we got
got the
guy this is good fire up the quantum
computers dude crunch the numbers a
crack Squad dude these guys are good up
next is Shane's most recent appearance
on this past weekend oh I didn't even
get under the covers it was right when I
checked in oh that's sad I just stripped
down went straight to it you did yeah
what is it that makes us do that you
know hotel rooms it's almost like you
know some birds when they after they'
flown for a long way they like vomit
right when they land and the number one
moment on this list comes to us from
Theo and Shane's first ever episode you
were sticking your dick in books and
smashing it not putting them in I would
open the book like the book was I'm not
saying the book was asking for but I
saying yes I think I just wanted to I
don't know if I wanted to meet a woman
from the past or if I